a set full of nine and ten-year-olds
pretending to be witches and wizards
you can bet there were lots of
shenanigans while filming i am so lucky
how many kids in the world would pay to
be doing this right now rupert grint and
daniel radcliffe found themselves so
overwhelmed and excited by what they got
to do on set that sometimes they became
a bit too distracted grint in particular
was a huge fan of all the wizarding
world goodies
and he definitely didn't mind having to
eat them take after take after take
unfortunately the young actor found
himself a bit too engrossed in his
candies and wound up missing cues
well do it again
because you were supposed to you're
supposed to be right on top of him
rupert would thought he'd be older did
you filming definitely ended up taking a
bit longer than they'd anticipated he
says we're gonna do that scene again i
might collapse
this wasn't radcliffe's first acting job
but he still had some things to learn
ben
remember to announce it keep your head
up his talent isn't a question at all
but his ability to keep his head up
while performing was definitely an issue
for this production head up dan your
head is too far down
it might just be the note that chris
columbus gave the young harry potter
actor the most throughout the entire
process all right dan remember looking
up hold your head up head up
hopefully once it was time to film the
chamber of secrets radcliffe was well
versed on this lesson
just because they weren't performing for
the cameras doesn't mean radcliffe and
grint took any breaks at all
in fact between takes the boys sometimes
decided to start putting on a musical
production of their own listen listen
dimpled woman we know you're in a hurry
but can we have please everything that
is on your trolley the talent was
clearly flowing out of them so it's no
surprise the production team just let
that magic happen
next to the zebras in cage 52
this definitely provided some great
entertainment for those in charge of
filming the behind the scenes
no one can say rupert grint didn't have
his head in the game the only issue is
sometimes he wasn't in the same game as
the rest of the team without even
noticing grint very confidently
addressed miss hermione granger as mr i
know everything he may have flubbed the
line but it's hard to find an actor who
can do so just as confidently when he
wasn't busy performing grid started
dabbling with directing acting as a
quasi-narrator for the making of the
first harry potter movie he was ready to
direct his co-stars
dan
say i can't look at you right now i'm
looking at the grass handle the camera
zoom in on your teeth
give actors cues
his passion for the franchise is
definitely evident and was useful for
capturing the best behind the scenes
evidently acting is just one of his many
talents
not only was she performing emma watson
was acting with giant teeth in her mouth
i'm having a teeth test
while they looked pretty good the fake
teeth hindered the actress's ability to
actually speak clearly so they wound up
being cut of all the footage that was
captured with watson and the buck teeth
one scene actually did make the final
cut
being so mature and skilled for his age
it was hard to spook or throw off the
harry potter actor so the director had
to get a bit creative before filming
warwick davis was instructed to be a bit
more aggressive as the gringotts goblin
in an attempt to frighten radcliffe so
they could try to capture a genuine
terrified reaction from him even a
surprise wouldn't do it daniel reacted
in a totally unexpected way bursting out
laughing on the scene the take obviously
couldn't work but it definitely lifted
everyone's moods on set
while it was inevitable there would be
multiple takes working with such young
actors in this particular case it wasn't
because anyone didn't know their lines
but rather because emma watson knew
everyone's lines a little bit too well
much like her character hermione the
actress was over achieving and memorized
all of her co-stars lines
if all snape wants the sorcerer's stone
widely try and kill you during the
quidditch match this could be a great
help to her on set but unfortunately she
unknowingly was mouthing along the
entire time meaning the team had to
shoot multiple takes until they finally
captured some footage where watson's
mouth wasn't moving all the time a bunch
of young actors pretending how to fly
for the very first time on broomsticks
you can bet the set was a bit chaotic
between takes and even sometimes while
filming scenes moments were ruined by
giggles and distractions
these nine and ten-year-olds got to not
only perform but actually witness the
big broom stunt that matthew lewis did
as neville
this was enough to get anyone excited
somehow amidst all the chaos they
managed to capture all the incredible
scenes that we know and love even when
she wasn't playing the part of professor
mcgonagall maggie smith did her best to
keep the young actors in line
she was amazing at working with the kids
which is saying something since so many
of the young actors were genuinely
frightened of alan rickman for years
if anyone's focus was ever off smith
wasn't shy to show that she was ready to
discipline with a scroll
i'm jamie i'm the commentator of this
slap scratch harry potter was the name
and slaps was the game on set bonding
moments like this between takes help the
actors feel comfortable with each other
and grow to be the family that they
eventually were all right
watson definitely let her competitive
edge show slaps wasn't just a fun game
to get rid of some excess energy
the young cast took it very seriously
it's leviosa
not leviosa it's arguably one of
hermione's all-time best lines but she
wasn't able to so flawlessly tell ron
what was what from the get-go emma
watson definitely had a lot on her plate
there are 50 billion trillion million
things going on at the same time
that you have to think about and
sometimes she just couldn't get through
the scene wingardium leviosa was an epic
line for us and no doubt an extremely
memorable experience to film filled with
tons of laughter since so many of the
young actors were experiencing a film
set for the first time it's not too
surprising that they could get
distracted at times and often totally
lose focus in the middle of a scene dan
don't play with that no don't be
laughing damn just a little more serious
okay director chris columbus had his
work cut out for him both directing and
trying to keep actors focused long
enough just to capture what they needed
typically making a mistake during an
audition is a big no-no for actors but a
broken prop during an improvisation
during one of radcliffe's auditions
wound up being the perfect opportunity
to charm the team i think chris columbus
broke a real egg
and made me laugh
we have a feeling by this point he
already had the role in the bag so this
sweet blooper just affirmed how fun and
easy-going radcliffe would be to work
with
no one can say the harry potter actor
wasn't committed to his craft when he
wasn't performing magic on screen the
actor was actually trying his hand at
real-life magic
with the on-set crew as his audience
radcliffe would often test out his
different skills and it seems like he
definitely improved over the process is
that your card
yes
all the fun these actors had on set is
just one of the many reasons that the
harry potter franchise turned out to be
so memorable how much magic do you think
radcliffe knew by the end of the
franchise